I lived with my grandmother for four and
a half years mate yeah and all she cares
about is looking after her man and I've
got she ironed she ironed my socks my
underwear my pillowcases like she wanted
to look after a man by ironing and
cooking and cleaning I don't agree with
him
she was tradition that's what the women
back in the day would love to do and
that's almost what that was up their
mentalities I don't want that I want my
girl to be out there starting her own
business and being a being XYZ being the
CEO of this business hang on because I
want her to be independent look after I
said I don't want to rely on me for her
money and and gas her up she should have
her own confidence and look after
herself and come home to me and be like
[ __ ] you know you never guess what I did
today I'll smash this yes that's what I
want but when it comes to like when we
decided to have babies and have children
she looks after them babies I wouldn't
want anybody else in this world to look
after our children apart from apart from
the mother but if she wants to go back
to work or run or run a business from
home absolutely she can do that like I
don't agree with name traditions of
staying at home and being a stay-at-home
mum and all that [ __ ] you're going
to get problems
what do you think that stay-at-home
mothers do what is your opinion of
estate our mothers because you got them
down like slavery slaves
no just let me explain something to you
right tradition no no no no no I know
most traditional Housewives yeah they've
got side hustle today no no no no they
didn't explain to you my grandmother
died a few years ago hundred and odd
years ago she always had a side hustle
okay she's made for you she's running a
million she's running a million all the
women in my family who were Housewives
always have a side hustle
my brother is married my brother is 40.
yeah he's married yeah he's my life has
a side hustle okay she she goes to work
and she said they both share yeah so
yeah but let's not be naive in the fact
of thinking that's that traditional
women back in the day were stay-at-home
wives let's not be no I'm trying to say
is that because you stay at home it
don't mean that I know exactly that's
I'm not denying that but what I'm saying
is you're saying about Traditional
Values and modern Traditional Values say
that an old school Woman by the
exception were stay-at-home moms are
cooked and cleaned and look after the
kids they didn't go to work and then
sign money
so you're trying to what you don't
understand is that
the women that stayed at home and cooked
and cleaned yeah right most of them did
not have a side hustle correct they did
not you're trying to tell me that all
those people back in the day they never
grew their own vegetables they never
baked their own bread for themselves for
themselves that is a side house
[Laughter]
you're serious yes
you know something right useless but use
not to be surprised at what a side
hustle is okay Define understand what
you mean aside how does this anything
that what you're going to say your
household that brings money into the
household anything that stops spend
money going out of the household me
personally right I I must I say I stay
at home and I bake cakes yeah I cater
for parties yeah I grow my own
vegetables yeah right to me okay but a
modern definition of a side hustle would
cancel that yeah and say that a modern
definition of a side hustle is bringing
in money and so you're having a
secondary income from a woman who stays
at home you're talking about a modern
definition I'm telling you what
tradition is exactly
your view of what tradition is
like stay at home cooking and cleaning
this no I'm trying to say to you there's
more to it than that of course there is
more to it than that bad hustle so I
believe in a woman that has old school
traditions in the fact how many how many
old people like their knitted scarves
and stuff like that and for most of them
most of them
most of them yeah so I love them I love
a modern woman today he's got a modern
values that wants to work hard work our
own job have our own company start our
own business become a CEO of xyze but
when it comes to having the babies and
whatnot I wouldn't want anyone else
somebody said that though I wouldn't
want anyone else
you know what hang on I know girls
senior company and have babies at work
at home time
so a traditional woman can stay at home
and work at home
because she's got traditional value for
the internet the internet
no it's not it's a modern woman
it's a traditional that's what it is
she's got she's got her own job and
she's got her own business she might be
she might be an influencer she might
have xyzes this that influencer you're
gonna get problems
she's at home she's raising my kids I
don't want anybody else I don't want a
nanny I don't want XYZ I want him to be
at home with my the woman I've chosen to
spend the rest of my life with please
completely against what being a boss
[ __ ] is no it doesn't see no no he does
I'm telling you something I'm telling
you something oh listen but no because
you're gonna bang your head against
because what it is you're going to meet
women that can give you this yeah but
you're going to want them to submit to
give it and they're not going to admit
to what no because in order for her to
go back into a position where she's
going to be a housewife and what you
want she has to happen to your housewife
because bro you wanted to look up how
you wanted to be a CEO flying out I mean
I wouldn't get a woman I said that
earlier you asked me aren't you what if
I think I wouldn't get a Woman Who
Wasn't maternal no just because she runs
her own business it doesn't mean she
doesn't understand
but what I'm trying to say to you is
yeah you're making the description that
women make for the type of man they want
because they want a man to go out there
to earn to be a higher fly the rest of
it yeah all you really needed for you to
say was you know what I want my wife to
be loyal maternal give me peace whatever
do whatever I stand yeah but then if you
want to say that to me it sounded like
you were describing your perfect man
yeah I was like
when you hear women talking about what
they want their Alpha man to have he
described an alpha man okay what he
described them no just by going what you
said why do you want a woman who's just
constantly relying on you
said that no one said that see nobody
said that why am I describing enough
because you do an extreme you do an
extreme way if it's not if it's a woman
can have modern values but traditional
but work on a woman's thing wait hold on
a second what kind of woman like um like
what your nan did for example yeah and
she loved to do that why do you attach
it to the fact that she was a slave or
she didn't want to do it I didn't say
that no no no no but when you say when
you talk about oh yeah I don't wanna I
don't want a woman to that's gonna have
to stay at home you made it sound like
so bad derogatory but there's so many
times
that is not derogatory no women can't
you keep missing the fact women can do
what they want but what do you want do
you want a bus [ __ ] that's gonna run a
CEO Company which is going to take about
20 hours a day do you know how much
noise
because in reality in life life is not
you have to make life life is about
choices and trade us right we cannot
have everything that we want and anyone
that's won the business knows that this
is not 12 hours a day it's actually
about 18 20 sometimes and when you go to
a woman that's running the CEO
accomplished she's not gonna be at home
chilling do you know what it is so if
you want a woman to do that at the same
time you better sit at home
obviously Back in the Day Men could
afford to just look after their women
and look after everything but obviously
things have changed it's a lot more
expensive and men nowadays they want
that but can you really afford that
lifestyle to look after the woman look
after everything and really and you know
what I mean and the woman just stay at
home and do nothing how much is a
submission cost how much does a manual
today
how much does Amanda need to earn a year
for you more than me
that minute she just said that
for in order for a woman to stay at home
and do all these things a man in the old
days
what you fail to realize is that
no matter how much money a man brings in
a real woman can manage it yeah correct
no because back in the day and it's not
for the fact that well it's not for the
fact that bills these day and ages is
just different like makeup bills and
eyelash bills and fingernail bills
so how much is the money to earn that's
depending on the women some women don't
care so you've got it on 30 grand a year
or you can earn 300. no but what we're
trying to say is that she must know that
in order to stay home like the lady at
home would she be willing to stay home
if a man at a 20 000 pounds a year that
wouldn't that wouldn't cover them
exactly
exactly and that's what he's saying how
much would it take you to stay at home
stay at home and take care of yourself
you can't answer that question well you
can
ask him for me or you asking I can't
answer your lifestyle
[Music]
very expensive
okay Brittany for the life that you live
in now yeah for you to stay at home for
you to have a child no it's not a stupid
it's a very because you guys said we're
talking about men oh we're talking about
men's I was like okay cool in order for
you to feel comfortable and
fundamentally what do you need how much
money I don't it's like it's not a trick
question it just generally it could be a
hundred thousands 100. let's be real I
love going on loads of holidays that's
something I pay for myself so then is he
going to be paying for no that's what
we're saying yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes so then you can't really put a
figure on it
this way like no but do you go to buy
the sweet dreams
you want to have kids you want to throw
a house and you wanna do the holidays
that mean you do exactly think about it
and remember your finances
so why can't you just say 150. I just I
obviously just why I can't even say it
150 Grand I need my man to earn 150
Grand it's simple yeah cool done
150 Grand he cannot sustain your
lifestyle it's simple so any man that's
trying to come out there and that's fine
if he can't but then I need to go to
work I'm working as well yeah
yeah yeah yeah my point is yeah is that
in today's day and age I feel as though
I think my grandmother who I lived with
and I've spent my whole life with yeah
she raised me in the I know that the old
school women back in those days they
were to look stay at home look like they
weren't Breadwinners yeah
majority of the time they went to look
after the babies cook clean this that
and the other bar that's it yeah today's
day and age that's it yeah but for the
most part it was yeah
for the most part as a woman I know
there's more to it that's it but go
ahead that's it but what I'm trying to
say is in today's day and age women
don't want that women wanna one women
want to be independent want to earn
their own money they want to look after
themselves not having to think about I
have to rely on a man so I think
guessing you'll go up to go and do that
sort of stuff he's [ __ ] top priority
no no yeah and but but when it comes to
then raising a family doesn't mean she
can't run a company from working at home
living I'll do my best to be at home and
look after them kids as well as much as
possible but I wouldn't want it when the
woman has a kid let her take a year out
and raise that baby that's the most
important year of the life I want to be
there for six months if I [ __ ] I could
to take to take time off work to be
there and raise my kid with my wife but
like I wouldn't want anybody else
raising that kid that's so great the way
you're seeing it I can't wait for your
CEO
I can't wait I can't wait for you to get
it
I'm just gonna
have these kids and work from at home
with the children I hope I'll be there
as much as I can though invite me to the
wedding you can sound like this and use
the car and put a plate you're winning
and young lady as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible